frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wer die Bilder und Berichte wahrnimmt
die uns seit dem 24 Februar Tag für Tag
aus der Ukraine erreichen kann nur zu
einem Ergebnis kommen in diesem Wochen
geht ein besonders schweres Jahr zu Ende
Russlands anders Krieg gegen die Ukraine
ist ein entsetzlicher Einschnitt er
trifft zuallererst die Ukraine und
Ukraine sie ertragen seit fast zehn
Monaten Vertreibung und Verschleppung
Verwundung und Tod
aber ein Einschnitt eine Zeitenwende
bedeutet Russlands Kriegs für ganz
Europa und die Welt
die Themen des Europäischen Rates morgen
in Brüssel spiegeln den Ernst der Lage
in die Putin unseren Kontinent gestürzt
hat wieder sie belegen aber noch etwas
und vor allem darüber will ich heute
sprechen
sie belegen wie fundamental Putin sich
verrechnet hat
Putin glaubte seine Truppen würden die
Ukraine innerhalb von Tagen über Rennen
er glaubte wir in Europa und
demokratischen Westen sein zu uneinig um
der Ukraine wirksam zu helfen
er glaubte er könne Europas Solidarität
Austrocknen indem er uns den Gashahn
zudreht
aber kein einziger von putinsplänen ist
aufgegangen
weil Putin sich getäuscht hat über den
Mut der ukraineren Ukraine über Europa
über uns über den Charakter unserer
Demokratien über unseren Willen und zu
widersetzen gegen Großmacht waren und
Imperialismus
meine Damen und Herren das ist die
wirkliche Geschichte dieses Jahres 2022
die Ukraine widersteht der russischen
Aggression aber auch wir haben die
Herausforderungen angenommen
gemeinsam mit unseren Freunden und
Partnern haben wir die Ukraine
entschlossen unterstützt finanziell
humanitär und auch mit Waffen diese
Unterstützung setzen wir fort und zwar
genau so lange wie sie benötigt wird
auch deshalb kämpfen die tapferen
Streitkräfte der Ukraine immer
erfolgreicher
und weil das so ist geht Russland dazu
über die ukrainische Infrastruktur zu
zerstören wehrlose Kinder Frauen und
alte mit Raketen zu beschießen
was für eine furchtbare und zugleich
völlig verzweifelte Strategie der
verbrannten Erde
aber auch damit kommt Putin nicht durch
weil die Ukraine und Ukrainer
zusammenstehen und standhalten und weil
wir die Ukraine umso mehr unterstützen
mit allem was sie braucht um auch dieser
niederträchtigen Art der Kriegsführung
zu widerstehen
dazu gehören jetzt Stromgeneratoren und
Transformatoren genauso wie die
Artillerie und Flugabwehrsysteme die wir
liefern
es sind ja nicht zuletzt die gepard-flag
Panzer aus Deutschland die hochwirksam
dazu beitragen dass ziemlich viele
russische Flugkörper abgeschossen werden
und gerade jetzt geht es dazu auch um
konkrete Maßnahmen zur Versorgung der
Ukraine mit Wärme Wasser und Strom
deshalb bin ich unserem französischen
Freunden besonders Emmanuel macron sehr
dankbar für die gestern in Paris
veranstaltete solidaritätskonferenz
dabei ging es gezielt darum wie die
Widerstandskraft der Ukraine in diesem
Winter mit Blick auf die Instandsetzung
der Energieinfrastruktur gestärkt werden
kann
auch im Europäischen Rat werden wir uns
darüber weiter abstimmen
zugleich sorgen wir dafür dass die
Ukraine auch 2023 die finanziellen
Mittel bekommt die sie braucht zusammen
mit den internationalen Partnern hat
Europa der ukrainischen Regierung seit
Kriegerinnen bereits umfangreiche
Finanzhilfen geleistet für 2023 stellt
die EU der Ukraine weitere 18 Milliarden
Euro an außerordentlicher Finanzhilfe
planbar und zielgerecht zur Verfügung
denn die Ukraine muss jetzt in die Lage
versetzt werden diesen Winter zu
überstehen
mit Blick auf die Zukunft will ich hier
aber auch anmerken
wer immer glaubt er könne die Grundwerte
der EU zu denen sich alle
Mitgliedsstaaten verpflichtet haben
ausspielen gegen die Außen- und
sicherheitspolitische Handlungsfähigkeit
der Union der wird damit scheitern
meine Damen und Herren auch die Arbeit
am Marshallplan für die lang den
langfristigen wieder auf der Ukraine
kommt voran im Oktober haben wir
führende Experte und Experten der Welt
hier in Berlin zusammengebracht um dafür
Konzepte zu entwickeln jetzt treiben wir
die Bildung einer internationalen
geberplattform voran die den
Wiederaufbau koordinieren wird erst
vorgestern haben wir uns mit unserem
Partnern in der G7 und mit der EU auf
Eckpfeiler dieser Plattform geeinigt
zugleich werden wir in der G7 weiter
zusammenarbeiten um weltweit die
Schwächsten in der Welt vor den Folgen
dieses kriegeses zu schützen in dem
Russland auch Ernährung und Energie
gezielt als Waffe einsetzt
parallel dazu erhöhen wir den
sanktionsdruck auf Putins Regime
das Embargo der EU für Öl aus Russland
ist ein Kraft seit vorletzter Woche gilt
in Europa in den G7 und darüber hinaus
der vereinbarte ölpreisdecke
die Sanktionen gegen Russland werden wir
so lange aufrechterhalten und weiter
verschärften wie Putin seinen brutalen
Angriffskrieg fortsetzt
meine Damen und Herren der russische
Angriffskrieg bedeutet eine
Herausforderung für den Zusammenhalt der
Europäischen Union
aber auch diese Herausforderung haben
wir angenommen gemeinsam und stark
Europa steht seit dem 24 Februar fest
zusammen dafür hat die Bundesregierung
von Anfang an gearbeitet wir haben
unsere Partner unterstützt und umgekehrt
ihre Unterstützung erfahren das ist
gelebte europäische Solidarität
auch im Hinblick auf die Verteidigung
unserer Freiheit und Sicherheit in
Europa haben wir die vergangenen Monate
intensiv genutzt hier in Deutschland in
Europa und in der NATO haben wir uns
verteidigungspolitisch neu ausgerichtet
unsere Bündnispartner wissen genau sie
können sich auf uns verlassen sie wissen
wir werden falls nötig jeden einzelnen
Quadratmeter des bündnisgebiets
verteidigen
dafür haben wir das Sondervermögen von
100 Milliarden beschlossen die größte
Investition in unsere Bundeswehr seit
ihrem bestehenden wird damit möglich
dafür rüsten wir unsere Streitkräfte
nach Jahren der Vernachlässigung endlich
angemessen aus
dafür beschaffen wir moderne F35
Kampfjets und leisten weiter unseren
deutschen Beitrag zur Teilhabe in der
Allianz
dafür halten wir in diesem Jahr und in
den nächsten beiden Jahren bis zu 17.000
Soldaten für die NATO response fast vor
dafür übernehmen wir 2023 erneut die
Führung der schnellen
nato-eingreiftruppe
dafür werden wir ab 2025 für die
NATO-Streitkräfte Struktur dauerhaft
30.000 Soldaten bereitstellen
dafür sind wir mit Kräften des Heeres
und der lufthafe in der slowakei-präsent
dafür sichern wir mit unserer Luftwaffe
und den Luftraum über Estland oder
erhöhen die Präsenz unserer Marine in
der Ostsee
dafür haben wir den nato-gefechtsverband
in Litauen dauerhaft verstärkt und
verbessern so die Verteidigung des
ganzen Baltikums
dafür verstärken wir gemeinsam mit
Norwegen und anderen Küstenstaaten aus
NATO EU den Schutz von Pipelines und
anderer kryptischer offshore
Infrastruktur
und dafür habe ich vor drei Monaten in
Prag auch den Vorschlag gemacht ein
raketenschutzschirm aufzubauen um so die
europäischen Fähigkeiten innerhalb der
NATO zu stärken
es ist gut dass sie schon 15 Partner
unserer Initiative angeschlossen haben
und es ist gut dass wir in der EU
beschlossen haben unsere Partner
weltweit allen voran die Ukraine mit
neuen Mitteln der europäischen
friedensfaszialität weiter zu
unterstützen
mit allen diesen Maßnahmen stärken wir
nicht nur die Sicherheit unserer Freunde
und Alliierten sind zugleich auch unsere
eigene Sicherheit
mit allen diesen Maßnahmen stärken wir
das Vertrauen aller Partner in unsere
Bereitschaft im Bündnis Verantwortung zu
übernehmen diesen Kurs haben wir seit
dem 24 Februar entschlossen
eingeschlagen diesen Kurs halten wir
meine Damen und Herren Europas
Sicherheit das bedeutet auch Europas
Energiesicherheit
auf keinem anderen Gebiet haben wir in
so kurzer Zeit so großen Fortschritt
erzielt
nichts beweist das so deutlich wie die
Eröffnung des ersten schwimmenden
Terminals für Flüssiggas den wir am
Sonnabend in Wilhelmshaven feiern können
im Juli war Baubeginn und jetzt ist
dieses erste deutsche LG Terminal fertig
schon diese Woche wird das erste Schiff
mit Flüssiggas in Wilhelmshaven anlegen
seit Monaten habe ich das angekündigt
und seit Monaten haben mich Leute
unglaublich angeguckt und gesagt noch in
diesem Jahr das wird doch nie was
das hat vermutlich auch Wladimir Putin
gedacht
aber das
ist was geworden und die nächsten
Terminals folgen in Kürze in lubminen in
Brunsbüttel und den Stade
ich glaube ich spreche im Namen von
allen oder fast allen in diesem Haus
wenn ich sage herzlichen Dank an alle
Arbeiter und Arbeiter an alle Ingenieure
und Ingenieure die im Rekordtempo diese
großartige Leistung vollbracht haben
auch ihnen verdanken wir dass wir in
diesem Jahr gut durch den Winter kommen
so sie stehen für viele Millionen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unserem Land
die in dieser schwierigen Zeit einfach
anpacken die mit ihrem Zusammenhalt und
mit ihrer guten Arbeit dafür sorgen dass
wir über die Runden kommen
auf jede und jeden von ihnen kommt es an
mit unseren entlastungspaketen und dem
200 Milliarden Abwehrschirm gegen die
Folgen des russischen Angriffskrieg tut
die Bundesregierung alles nur Mögliche
um die Lage der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und der Unternehmen zu erleichtern so
und nur so kommen wir gemeinsam durch
diese Zeit
meine Damen und Herren gemeinsam das
bedeutet vor allem gemeinsam in Europa
nie zuvor haben wir ein Energiefragen so
eng zusammengearbeitet wir haben uns
auch gemeinsame Energiesparziele
geeinigt und wir haben uns darauf
verständigt dass wir die hohen
Strompreise abfedern
wir arbeiten am gemeinsamen Einkauf von
Gas so dass wir auch nächstes Jahr
unsere Speicher gut füllen können
dabei ist klar einfacher Sofortlösung
gibt es nicht zum Beispiel können wir
nicht so in Preise Eingreifen dass dann
zu wenig Gas nach Europa geliefert wird
diese Einsicht ist auch für die
Verständigung wichtig an der der
energierat der EU gestern
weitergearbeitet hat und ich bin sicher
wir werden eine gute pragmatische
Verständigung erzielen
meine Damen und Herren in einer weiteren
Hinsicht erweist sich Putins Krieg als
Beschleuniger notwendiger Veränderung
für den Umstieg auf erneuerbare Energie
steht diese Bundesregierung von Anfang
an aber jetzt ist klar die Erneuerbaren
brauchen wir nicht nur wegen der
Klimakrise wir brauchen sie auch zu
unserer Sicherheit damit wir nie wieder
zu abhängig sind von einzelnen
Lieferanten aus beiden Gründen arbeiten
wir daran dass Europa zum ersten
klimanotalen Kontinent wird und auch
dabei kommen wir schnell voran
viele Elemente des Pakets fit vor 505
der EU werden gegenwärtig noch
verhandelt wir setzen uns dabei ein für
ehrgeizige Ziele für den mutigen
Einstieg in die nächste große Epoche
unser europäischen Industriegeschichte
in der wir mit klimaneutraler
technologiesichere neue Arbeit und neuen
Wohlstand schaffen
meine Damen und Herren
auch in den Prozess der EU-Erweiterung
hat putinskrieg neuen Schwung gebracht
die Ukraine der Ukraine Moldau und
perspektivisch Georgien haben wir im
Juni den Weg zur EU-Mitgliedschaft
eröffnet
aber wir haben endlich auch wieder den
Beitrittsprozess der sechs Staaten des
westlichen Balkan unter dampfgesetzt das
ist mir ein besonderes Anliegen
das Gipfeltreffen des berlin-prozesses
am 3 november im Kanzleramt hat gezeigt
Konflikte der Vergangenheit sind wie wir
wieder spüren nicht vorüber aber
überwindbar
Fortschritte Richtung EU-Mitgliedschaft
ist möglich
diese Einschätzung habe ich letzte Woche
beim eu-westbal kein Gipfel in Tirana
ausdrücklich bekräftigt
dafür setze ich mich auch weiter in
energisch ein morgen beim Europäischen
Rat und auch im kommenden Jahr
da müsste es richtig das sind dieser
Woche auch Bosnien-Herzegowina zum
EU-Beitrittskandidaten wird es liegt in
unserem deutschen und in unserem
europäischen Interesse dass der
westliche balkanteil der Europäischen
Union wird
genauso liegt es in unserem Interesse
das Kroatien ab 23 zum Schengen Raum
gehören wird und es liegt in unserem
Interesse das Rumänien und Bulgarien
bald folgen
[Applaus]
das ist noch nicht gemacht aber wir
müssen auf diesem Weg weiter vorankommen
meine Damen und Herren Putins Krieg hat
auch bei vielen Fragen nach der Zukunft
der Globalisierung und nach Europas
Rolle in der Welt des 21 jahrhunderts
neue Klarheit geschaffen heute Mittag
reise ich ja zuerst zum eu-asiengipfel
in Brüssel
das wird das erste Gipfeltreffen
überhaupt dass die Regierungschefs der
EU und des asiatischen staatenverbandes
so zusammenbringt gemeinsam haben die 10
Asien Staaten 670 Millionen Einwohner
wir in der EU sind 450
schon diesem normzahlen zeigen die
Vorstellung einer bipolaren Ehre in der
sich alles um die USA und China dreht
geht an der globalen Wirklichkeit vorbei
natürlich an der herausgehobenen Rolle
der USA besteht kein Zweifel auch nicht
an der Rivalität zwischen den USA und
China
mit unserem wichtigsten globalen Partner
den USA verbinden uns Europäer dabei
vielfältige gemeinsame Werte und
Interessen
gerade dieses Jahr wieder gezeigt wie
unverzichtbar das transatlantische
Bündnis ist
das schließtdifferenzenden Einzelfragen
nicht aus die amerikanischen
Investitionen in den Klimaschutz sind
ein beeindruckender Beitrag zur
Transformation der US-Wirtschaft und
auch das muss an dieser Stelle und hier
gesagt werden lange haben wir uns
gewünscht dass eine solche Zielrichtung
in den USA verfolgt wird
aber sie dürfen auch das ist klar nicht
den fairen Wettbewerb verhindern darum
unterstütze ich sehr dass die
Europäische Kommission intensive
Gespräche mit den USA führt ich habe mit
dem amerikanischen Präsidenten
gesprochen der französischen Präsident
hat das auch getan denn wir dürfen uns
im transatlantischen Verhältnis nicht
auseinander dividieren lassen im
Gegenteil statt einer großen
Auseinandersetzung sollten wir noch
enger zusammenarbeiten und den
gemeinsamen und fairen Handel mit den
USA stärken
meine Damen und Herren Chinas Aufstieg
zur Weltmacht ist eine Tatsache mit der
wir zurechtkommen müssen
dabei wäre es falsch zurechtkommen mit
abkoppeln zu übersetzen mit die kappling
oder die Globalisierung das wäre nicht
der richtige Weg als Wirtschafts- und
Handelspartner bleibt China für uns
wichtig
und über viele globale fragen wollen und
müssen wir mit China sprechen auch da wo
wir eben unterschiedlich auf
Sachverhalte blicken
bei meinem Besuch in China habe ich klar
zum Ausdruck gebracht dass Deutschland
Europa für eine Regel basierte
internationale Ordnung einstehen fest
verankert in der Kater der Vereinten
Nationen
unsere Sorgen über die wachsende
Unsicherheit im Südchinesischen Meer und
in der Straße von Taiwan habe ich sehr
deutlich formuliert das war wichtig
aber wichtig war zugleich das Präsident
Ski und ich in einer entscheidenden
Frage einig war
ein nicht darüber dass bereits die
Drohung mit dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen
und zulässig ist einig darüber dass der
Einsatz von Atomwaffen eine rote Linie
überschreiten würde die die Menschheit
zu Recht gezogen hat
ich hoffe sehr dass diese klare und
gemeinsame Botschaft auch in Moskau
angekommen ist mit seinem gewalttätigen
Großmacht waren steht Russland heute so
alleine da wie nie zuvor auf dem
G20-Gipfel kürzlich auf Party war das
für alle Welt zu sehen
meine Damen und Herren
die Welt ist 21 jahrhunderts wird eine
multipolare Welt sein wenn zum Lösung
für die großen globalen Themen geht
Klimaschutz Pandemien Biodiversität oder
Digitalisierung dann müssen wir unsere
Netze weiter auswerfen
dann müssen wir nicht nur unsere
lieberketten diversifizieren sondern
auch unsere Verhandlungen und
Verbindungen alle Teile der Welt dann
brauchen wir enge und vertrauensvolle
Partnerschaften besonders mit den
aufstrebenden Nationen in Asien in
Afrika in Leitner in Amerika und in der
Karibik
darum haben wir zum diesjährigen
g7-gipfel in Emma auch die
Regierungschefs wichtiger demokratische
Staaten des globalen Südens eingeladen
darum bin ich in diesem Jahr gezielt in
Länder wie Vietnam und Singapur Japan
und Indonesien Südafrika Senegal oder
Niger gereist
darum habe ich Premierminister Modi zu
deutsch-indischen
Regierungskonsultationen empfangen und
darum haben wir unsere gesamte deutsche
g7-präsidentschaft genutzt um für die
Gründung eines offenen kooperativen
internationalen klimaklubs zu werben um
so den globalen Klimaschutz
voranzubringen
es ist ein erfreulicher Abschluss
unserer Präsidentschaft dass die G7
Anfang dieser Woche den Rahmen dieses
Clubs förmlich beschlossen hat
wir werden jetzt schnell auf weitere
Staaten zugehen damit der klimclub zu
vereinten Anstrengungen gegen den
Klimawandel führt
meine Damen und Herren
niemand leidet so sehr unter Russlands
Angriffskrieg wie die Ukraine an
Ukrainer wir stehen fest an ihrer Seite
aber auch uns Deutsche unsere Freunde
und Partner hat putinskrieg vor enorme
Herausforderungen gestellt
diese Herausforderung und Aufgaben haben
wir angenommen an diesen
Herausforderungen sind wir gemeinsam
gewachsen
und diejenigen die nicht geglaubt haben
dass wir das können die haben sich
gewaltig geirrt
das ist die gute Nachricht die am Ende
dieses so bitteren Jahres zuversichtlich
stimmt wir in Deutschland haben
gemeinsam den richtigen Weg
eingeschlagen wir stehen zusammen wir
lassen niemanden allein
[Applaus]